الان نتواجد في التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه
هذه التوسعه التي
هي على في مراحيلها الاخيره للانتهاء
اليوم نتحدث عن توسعه تسع لاكثر من 900
الف مصلي قرابه مساحه تتجاوز المليون متر
مربع طبعا التوسعه هي مكونه من عده ابواب
اكثر من ثمانين بابا فقط في هذه التوسعه
وايضا لو نضيف هذه المعلومه ان عدد
الابواب في المسجد الحرام ككل يتجاوز 210
ابواب طبعا اخذ في الطابع المعماري
والتصميم والاشكال الهندسيه بشكل مختلف
حيث تضيف
في تصميمه الحركه الانسيابيه وايضا الحركه
السلسه بالنسبه للمعتمرين او كذلك الحجاج
في موسم الحج اضافه الى عمليات ووحدات
التبريد ووحدات ايضا من عمليه تنقل
المعتمرين او كذلك الحجاج في موسم مثلا في
التطبيقات هناك توجد تطبيقات ذكيه اوجدتها
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين من خلال
بامكان الحجاج او كذلك المعتمرين
استخدامها
لطلب عربات كهربائيه او عربات عاديه ايضا
من ضمن التطبيقات والخدمات الذكيه التي
اوجدتها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين هي ايضا
تطبيقات في عمليه تنقل وانتقال المعتمر من
مكان الى اخر او كذلك الحاج في موسم الحج
من مكان الى اخر حقيقه الامر اليوم
التوسعه هي هذه
التوسعه مكتمله تماما ام لا مازال يجري
العمل على بعض اجزائها
نتحدث اليوم عن ما نسبته 98% هي منتهيه
بالكامل ونحن نتواجد في هذه التوسعه
الاثنين في المئه بامكاننا نتحدث عن
التشطيبات النهائيه وهي توجد في الخارج
خارج هذه التوسعه وتحديدا في الساحات
الخارجيه وهي في المرافق الاخرى التي تكمل
اعداد المصلين
وليصلوا الى اكثر من 900 الف مصلي ممتاز
من الحرم المكي الشريف مراسل العربيه هاني
نصفيان دائما شكرا جزيلا لك هاني على كل
هذه
المتابعه ورمضان كريم دائما لك ولجميع
المشاهدين